bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat journée spéciale sur
notre antenne consacré à la coop 21
opérations mobilisation à l'elysée ce
matin ou françois hollande a réuni de
nombreuses personnalités 400 diplomate
ministre ou encore entreprises
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs en direct à
midi vous avez pu entendre le discours
du chef de l'état qui a redit sa
détermination à réussir la coop 21
cette grande conférence réunira dans
trois mois à paris 195 état avec un
enjeu fondamental
il s'agit d'arriver à un accord
contraignant pour que ces 195 états
s'engagent à l'unité et leurs émissions
de gaz à effet de serre cela pour
limiter à deux degrés la hausse des
températures sur notre planète
2° c la limite au-delà de laquelle les
scientifiques prévoient des dégâts
irréversibles
cet après midi je vous propose de suivre
l'audition de laurence tubiana au sénat
c'est à la représentante spéciale de la
france pour la coop 21 sa mission être
notre ambassadrice sur les négociations
climatiques et montrait que la luttre
contre ce dérèglement est indispensable
montrer aussi que cette lutte peut
apporter des bénéfices majeurs en termes
de croissance d'emploi et de qualité de
vie
elle s'était exprimée au printemps
dernier au mois de mai devant les
sénateurs des commissions du
développement durable et des affaires
étrangères
regardez sommes très heureux
d'accueillir aujourd'hui madame tubes y
en a qui est ambassadrice chargée des
négociations sur le changement
climatique et la représentante spéciale
pour la conférence paris climat 2015
sadristes nous sommes très heureux de
vous accueillir un petit peu moins de
200 jours de cette conférence sommes
très heureux parce que nous savons que
nul mieux que vous
ne peut nous faire le point sur l'état
de préparation de cette conférence au
combien importante et sur ses chances de
succès quelques mots pour vous dire que
le sénat et est très mobilisé sur la
préparation de cette conférence
parce que nous sommes bien conscients
que c'est d'une conférence qui est
importante bien sûr pour la france
puisque c'est la france qui accueille
cette conférence mais elle est surtout
importante pour la planète et plus
encore pour l'humanité puisque comme le
dit souvent nicolas hulot c'est pas la
planète qui est en cause c'est
l'humanité nous mesurerons déjà un
certain nombre d'effets des dérèglements
climatiques y compris dans des pays
comme comme le nôtre avec la montée des
océans avec des phénomènes d'érosion des
côtes avec des événements climatiques
extrêmes de plus en plus fréquents nous
irons d'ailleurs dans pas très longtemps
sur la côte bordelaise voir les effets
de l'érosion des côtes dans cette dans
cette région et donc c'est pour cela que
le sénat est très mobilisé gérard
larcher présentera demain à la presse
les actions que le sénat entend mener
dans les semaines qui viennent et qu'il
a commencé à mener que nous avons eu la
semaine dernière un très intéressant
colloque sur les religions et le
réchauffement climatique qui était
extrêmement intéressant nous recevons
ici chaque fois qu'il y à des
parlementaires étrangers qui sont en
france nous les recevons pour faire le
point avec eux et pour essayer quand
c'est nécessaire de de les sensibiliser
nous avons au cours de la semaine passée
reçu des parlementaires canadiens nous
avions hier des staffeurs américains
avec lesquels nous avons eu des échanges
très intéressants et bien sûr nous
participons à la mobilisation des
territoires puisque le sénat vous le
savez la chambre qui représente les
territoires et que les territoires sont
ont un rôle aussi important en terme de
deux maîtrises d
dès l'émission des gaz à effet de serre
et puis je dois dire un mot sur la
préparation de la journée de lui paie la
journée de l'union interparlementaire
qui aura lieu au sénat le 6 décembre et
qui réunira des parlementaires des
différents états pour ce fut le cas à
lima et nous allons au cours de cette
réunion présenter une résolution j'ai
été nommé rapporteur de cette résolution
lors de l'assemblée générale de lui paie
et nous aimerions vraiment que cette
déclaration qui sera celle des
parlementaires et des parlementaires des
parlements pardon puisse figurer dans
les actes finaux de la conférence je le
dis parce que c'est vrai on l'a ressenti
à lima pour ce qu'ils étaient et
certains parlementaires l'on ressent
aussi dans d'autres circonstances les
parlements les parlementaires ont trop
souvent le sentiment d'être un peu à
l'écart de ces grandes négociations
je sais que c'est pas votre volonté
puisque vous m'avez déjà dit vous leur
direz peut-être aujourd'hui que c'est
important que les parlementaires se
mobilise auprès de leurs homologues
d'autres pays pour les sensibiliser pour
que les parlements respectifs des
différents pays puissent eux mêmes quand
c'est nécessaire faire pression sur les
gouvernements jeu je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on se parle
il n'y a que cudi contributions qui ont
été fournis pour la conférence de
décembre alors que normalement elle
devait tout être fournis pour la fin du
la fin du mois de mars
alors je voudrais que vous nous
indiquiez l'ambassadrice si à votre avis
on a encore aujourd'hui des chances
sérieuses d'arriver à un véritable
accord à paris c'est à dire un accord
contraignant et universel nous avons le
sentiment comme je le disais qu'il n'y a
pas un enthousiasme débordant puisque
j'ai indiqué qu'il n'avait que dix
contribution qui avait été fourni est ce
que vous disiez il n'y a pas très
longtemps qu'une accélération du
processus était nécessaire est ce
qu'elle peut est ce qu'elles peuvent
venir je crois qu'il ya une une session
de négociations à bonnat semaine
prochaine qu'est ce qu'on peut en
attendre
et puis nicolas hulot que nous avons
reçu il ya quelques semaines nous a
parlé de d'une course contre la montre
alors où en est on dans cette dans cette
course
et puis comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on aimerait également que vous
puissiez nous indiquer en cours à nous
parlementaires nous pouvons être utiles
nous pouvons encore être utile et
notamment auprès de quel pays faut-il
que nous sans trion notre action pour
faire en sorte de contribuer modestement
mais de contribuer quand même à la
réussite de cette conférence merci à
hervé madame l'ambassadrice quelques
mots rapides pour vous souhaiter au nom
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et notre président jean pierre raffarin
qui est malheureusement retenu en séance
publique
vous souhaitez de notre côté la
bienvenue et vous remercier d'avoir
accepté cette rencontre car nous savons
que votre agenda est particulièrement
chargé et votre implication dans ce
dossier est évidemment très important
effectivement le calendrier parce nous
approchons de cette date fatidique
et comme notre collègue le président
m'aurait vous l'a dit le sénat a pris
l'initiative de s'impliquer au travers
de ses différentes délégations de ses
différentes compétences pour prendre
toute sa part dans la préparation de
cette conférence internationale qui
suscite beaucoup d'espoirs je rappelle
pour l'histoire que la conférence de
copenhague s'était terminé par un
résultat en demi-teinte avec les
déclarations particulière d'un certain
de pays en voie de développement qui
posait qui nous posait à nous pays
occidentaux des questions dérangeantes
et donc les mêmes questions demeurent du
reste mais peut-être aurez-vous à coeur
de nous expliquer comment les choses ont
pu avancer
comment la prise de conscience des
grands des grands enjeux visant à
maintenir sur terre
un climat qui reste supportable est
favorable au développement des
populations et bien comment ces défis
peuvent être relevés pour ce qui
concerne la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense
nous nous sommes comme je le disais il
ya un instant mobilisés notamment à
travers un groupe de travail qui est
animé par cédric perrin qui
malheureusement n'est pas là mais aussi
par notre collègue mais il a échoué à
qui j'aurais l'occasion de donner la
parole tout à l'heure après votre
contribution et qui se focalise
notamment sur les conséquences
géopolitiques de la montée des eaux et
sur un sujet aussi tout à fait
passionnant dont on parle beaucoup ces
temps ci dure est la situation dans
l'arctique qui est un continent que nous
connaissons au moins et que nous
fréquentons mois mais qui pose aussi
beaucoup de questions pour l'avenir
hervé maurey rappelait la communication
de nicolas hulot qui était une
communication un peu contrastée dans
lequel il nous faisait part de sa
crainte ou en tous les cas d'un certain
nombre d'éléments de satisfaction mais
nous faisait pas aussi de ses craintes
et notamment de l'insuffisance du nombre
des premières contributions nationales
qui ont été déposés avant je crois à la
fin mars et qui ne le sont toujours pas
est ce que c est un retard administratif
ou bien est ce que c'est vous donner une
signification à ces retards est ce qu'il
ya des pays avec lequel les choses vont
mieux et d'autres moins bien
et puis surtout donc comment peut-on
mobiliser la société civile au niveau
mondial afin qu'un accord ne reste pas
lettre morte parce qu'il est toujours
facile de signer des accords
internationaux
encore faut-il que tous ces objectifs
soient partagées par nos populations et
que celle ci accepte parfois de faire
des sacrifices auxquels elles n'ont
point à l'habitude je voudrais au
passage rappelé que vous posez le
conseil d'administration de l'agencé
française de développement et qu'à ce
titre votre expérience dans ce
domaine-là la fréquentation
des pays en voie de développement et les
projets que l'afd mène dans ces pays
vous fait de vous une interlocutrice
tout à fait privilégié par rapport à ces
pays donc moi j'aimerais beaucoup pour
avoir été administrateur de l'afd avant
mon collègue henri de raincourt qui m'a
remplacé
j'aimerais beaucoup que vous puissiez
nous dire comment cette préparation de
la conférence s'effectue dans ces pays
qui ont des logiques et des
problématiques qui sont parfois
sensiblement différentes des nôtres même
s'ils sont souvent aussi les pays qui
supportent le plus les conséquences de
ces derrag le de ces dérèglements
climatiques
voilà quelques perspectives qui seront
certainement nourri par le jeu des
questions de nos collègues encore une
fois nous vous remercions parce que nous
mesurons l'immensité de la tâche qui
vous incombent et votre engagement
personnel entier pour que au nom de la
france cette conférence soit un succès
donc sur l'ensemble de ces enjeux de
cette négociation
quel bilan peut-on faire au jour
d'aujourd'hui
voilà quelques thématiques qui je crois
nous rirons cette rencontre donc ils
vont vous permettre pendant une
quinzaine de minutes si vous le voulez
bien de de nous présenter une synthèse
et puis après les rapporteurs prendront
la parole et bien sûr nos collègues
auront la liberté de vous poser toutes
les questions dans le temps que vous
nous consacrer je vous remercie madame
l'ambassadrice vous avez la parole
si beaucoup merci beaucoup de cette
invitation
c'est toujours un moment important
devant un groupe comme le vôtre de
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
j'ai toujours l'impression d'être un
garagiste dans les mains dans le
cambouis et de prendre un peu de recul
et se demander où on en est
effectivement un peu moins de 200 jours
avant avant la
l'étape finale si je puis dire vous avez
déjà là il ose poser beaucoup de
questions auxquelles je vais essayer de
répondre et peut-être en recadrant un
peu et je le fais d'autant plus que
laurent fabius n'a pas pu venir
devant vous expliquer la vision globale
de ce qu'on attend pour paris je vais
peut-être partir de là du point
d'arrivée pour essayer de revenir au
sommet s'est tracé le chemin déjà
parcouru et de chemin qui reste à
parcourir
et ce faisant répondre déjà à me
semble-t-il à quelques interrogations
vous avez soulevé alors vous vous l'avez
sans doute entendu à la fois d'une
manière ou d'une autre du ministre des
affaires étrangères et du président de
la république départ de la présidence de
la république
l'idée qu'on cherche à paris en tournant
non pas seulement un compromis de plus
sur une longue route de négociations qui
durent depuis 1992 jeu j'aime à dire
toutefois que même si cette période de
négociation vous paraît longue
les négociations sur la libéralisation
du commerce ont commencé en 1948
on peut estimer qu'elle était très
largement achevée il ya encore beaucoup
de secteurs sur lequel il ya du travail
en 1994 sur un sujet beaucoup plus
simple que celui du climat donc 92 a
aujourd'hui ça paraît long mais on est
c'est quand même moins long que ce qu'on
a déjà fait ce qu'on avait investi dans
le passé sur le commerce et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué juste pour se
donner un peu la difficulté d'accorder
ce qui au fond une évolution profonde
non seulement des politiques publiques
nationales mais aussi des modèles de
développement et c'est pour ça qu'on
cherche à paris à faire comprendre faire
sentir le fait qu' on est dans un
tournant que on faut que ce qu'on
cherche c'est à dire une économie très
sobre en carbone à terme très peu
fondée sur les ressources fossiles
notamment le charbon le pétrole ou le
gaz est on capable en tout cas n'est pas
aujourd'hui le cas de neutraliser ses
émissions de carbone dans l'atmosphère
et que donc on cherche à offert
converger des anticipations non
seulement des gouvernements et sont
évidemment très divers mais aussi d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs en particulier
les acteurs économiques mais aussi les
collectivités locales qui ont pris un
rôle très important dans cette diffusion
sur le crime a depuis bien des années
faire converger 7 ses anticipations pour
partager au fond à la fois l'objectif
général vraiment faire changer les
modèles de développement pour qu'on
puisse rester sous la barre de
l'augmentation de température moyenne de
2 degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle et du coup changé
profondément toute une série d'éléments
du développement économique
d'aujourd'hui sans pour autant renoncer
à ce développement
sans renoncer à la croissance économique
mais au fond des couples est
profondément les la consommation des
ressources fossiles
d'une certaine manière aussi un peu la
consommation d'énergie même si on peut
de plus en plus produire de l'énergie
propre par rapport au climat et la
croissance économique
donc cette convergence des anticipations
c'est au fond le jeu résultat qu'on
cherche à paris le 12 décembre on
aimerait voir dans les titres des
journaux
ça c'est fluoration pas comme ça de
façon plus concrète
cette économie sobre en carbone apparaît
inévitable c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est ce que qui est souhaitable et
c'est ce qu'au fond tous les acteurs
présents financiers économiques
industriels
gouvernements ou autorités locales
pensent que c'est ce qu'il faut faire et
c'est ce qui va arriver et donc on
cherche ça et pour chercher ça cette
convergence des anticipations parce que
il ya une bonne partie comme vous le
disiez c'est la mise en oeuvre l'accord
c'est une chose mais surtout c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe
et qu'est ce qui se passe c'est aussi ça
dépend de la conviction notamment des
acteurs économiques que c'est les
marchés nouveaux que c'est les solutions
technologiques sont à portée de main ou
que l'on voit comment les développer et
c'est une combi de une conviction
mutuelle des pouvoirs publics et des
acteurs privés pour qu on aille dans ce
chemin c'est pour ça qu'on présente là
le résultat de paris en quatre volets
l'accord lui-même sous pour lequel la
france a reçu un mandat en acceptant de
temps candidate pour être l'hôte de la
force
la cap 21 les contributions nationales
qui sont puisque nous sommes dans un
système qui est aujourd'hui parle on
appelle par le bas c'est à dire que
céder des actions d engagement
volontaire des pays sur cette réduction
des émissions est aussi aussi dans
d'autres domaines
donc ça c'est le deuxième volet du
résultat de paris les la mobilisation
des finances et donc la modification au
fond des réponses que le système
financier offre aujourd'hui j'ai besoin
d'investissements pour que ce système
financier temps et finances publiques
que les finances privées à répondre à ce
défi de la transition énergétique et
économique dans le monde vers ce monde
bas carbone et enfin les engagements des
acteurs non gouvernementaux car encore
une fois il faut construire cet effet de
croyance il faut montrer qu'il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
pensent que cette économie sobre en
carbone c'est l'avenir et qui
investissent qui pensent que l'économie
fondée sur les ressources fossiles
elle est risquée du point de vue
économique elle est aussi risqué parce
que elle elle a des conséquences en
matière d'impact de et y compris sur les
activités économiques du changement
climatique
c'est aussi le fait de vouloir montrer
que beaucoup d'autorités locales dont
dépendent beaucoup de décisions qui ont
un impact sur le climat notamment en
matière de planification urbaine
de politique de transport de enfin toute
la liste de ce que font les autorités
locales qu'elle aussi elle voit dans ces
villes durables danser dans ses plans de
réduction d'émissions ou d'adaptation au
changement climatique l'avenir de leur
collectivité et donc on voudrait qu'à
paris l'alliance de l'action pour le
climat l'eau le slogan de la cap 21 ans
et unissent dans l'action pour le climat
et qu'on m'a va matérialiser sur l'idée
d'un concept d'alliance de paris pour le
climat et cette alliance à représente à
la fois le travail juridique qu'on doit
faire l'accord
ces décisions nationales souveraines de
s'engager dans ce modèle de
développement et le la réponse du
système financier et enfin donc les
engagements des acteurs non
gouvernementaux et donc en partie qu en
pratique on a forcément du coup
puisqu'on veut c4 résultat une
diplomatie j'appelle ça à 360° parce que
l'on doit à la fois travailler avec les
gouvernements à différents niveaux chefs
d'état ministres négociateurs on doit
travailler je dirais non pas avec ceux
qui négocient seulement mais ceux qui
sont dans les pays en train de
construire les politiques énergétiques
des différents pays
enfin on doit aussi travailler avec des
acteurs du système financier
et enfin on a aussi des déployer
développer un site et ses acteurs non
gouvernementaux qui veulent s'engager à
le faire de façon compréhensible
vérifiables aussi pour que cela donne
confiance à tout le monde donc on a une
diplomatie sur tous ces éléments on est
évidemment puissamment aidé par un
réseau diplomatique qui reste
exceptionnel
à l'échelle mondiale une mobilisation
sans précédent de ce réseau diplomatique
je crois que grand étonnement de mes
collègues négociateur il n'avait jamais
vu avant un ambassadeur de france là il
le rencontre en général tous les mois et
demi
parfois ils trouvent que c'est même
beaucoup quoi et donc on a dans les
ambassades dans chaque poste
une mobilisation en direction des
négociateurs et les ministres ne gossip
des collectivités locales des industries
que c'est donc mobilisation 360 degrés
et peut-être maintenant en venir ou
est-ce qu'on en est alors vous m'avez
tendu une perche en disant qu est ce qu
on en est loin puisqu'on a que 10
contribution 37 ans comptant évidemment
les pays de l'union alors pourquoi ça ne
l'inquiète pas outre mesure le 31 mars
qu'était la date une date de pour les
pays qui peuvent le faire fixer à lima
donc si ce n'était pas une date
obligatoire la date butoir aller au
moins d'octobre
l'exercice est très compliqué jean
discuté hier avec la secrétaire
exécutive de la commission économique
pour l'amérique latine continent qui
s'est beaucoup mobilisée pour le climat
et dont les pays peine à rédiger leur
contribution en alicia barcena me disais
c'est une prise de conscience très très
très importante entre le dire qu'on veut
faire quelque chose pour le climat et
commencer à se dire en 2025 en 2030
comment je vais réduire les émissions
comment je vais le faire dans le secteur
de l'énergie dans le secteur des
transports dans le secteur dans le
secteur industriel est ce que j'utilise
des instruments de politique fiscale est
ce que je me fixe un objectif de
réduction absolue des émissions
tout ça est quelque chose pour beaucoup
de pays qui étaient parfaites qui
n'avait jamais été fait et il est normal
et quand je vois un peu la nature de la
préparation de la contribution chinoise
qui va être très détaillé c'est aussi
comme ici quand on a les amendements à
la loi transition énergétique c de même
nature
même si la portée du regard va pas tout
à fait aussi loin mais enfin 2025 ou
2030 c'est très c'est un fait non un
comme horizon air et ses débats cadre
politique dans chaque pays qui sont
extrêmement fortes
il ya évidemment les protestations des
industriels s'ils pensent que ça va
gêner leur développement ce qui est des
agriculteurs ou ou des forestiers qui
ont peur que ça enfin vous imaginez tous
les débats et partout il y à des débats
intenses à la fois la prise de
conscience des gouvernements que il
s'agit plus d'un espèce de chose un peu
abstraite que c'est très concret ça va
se traduire ça doit se traduire dans la
politique domestique et que c'est en
même temps
très très compliqué donc c'est normal
que ça prenne du temps c'est des
arbitrages complexe financier sur le au
fond le taux de croissance espéré sur
comment on va faire enfin et donc au
contraire moi je ne suis pas pessimiste
sur l'engagement des pays à présenter
des contributions je crois qu'on aura
beaucoup beaucoup peut-être pas 195
contribution à paris mais on aura très
largement les 99.99 recouvrant les
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre qui seront comprises dans ces
contributions et une bonne partie vont
arriver dans les semaines qui viennent
les autres pendant l'été je crois qu'en
octobre on aura en tout cas de quoi voir
où nous en sommes alors sûrement nicolas
hulot a partagé son ses inquiétudes sur
la nature de ces contributions pour et
ce pour ce qu'on en sait elles ne
pourront pas en tout cas l'horizon 2025
ou 2030 répondre à la question est ce
qu'on est sur la bonne trajectoire pour
respecter l'objectif collectif qu'on
s'est donné qui sera réaffirmée à paris
celui de ne pas dépasser cette
augmentation des 2 degrés par rapport à
l'ère préindustrielle c'est vrai ces
contributions soient encore plus
ambitieuse que précédemment
bien plus ambitieuse que précédemment
mais sans doute insuffisante et c'est
donc tout le tout l'enjeu de l'accord de
paris de prévoir comment on rattrape
progressivement cette trajectoire qui
est compatible avec degré qui est très
c'est une trajectoire sévères en matière
d'émissions mondiales il faut pas
oublier que c'est au moins 50% de
réduction des émissions mondiales par
rapport à 90 en 2050 même par rapport à
2000 et où ce qui est à peu près
équivalent c'est donc
une grande transformation ça veut dire
que les pays
beaucoup de pays en développement
commencent à réduire leurs émissions de
façon absolue évidemment c'est ce que la
chine a accepté en principe mais encore
faut-il qu'elles que ça sera
suffisamment tôt et suffisamment fort
c'est à dire que la descente ensuite des
émissions soient significatives
donc on a plein d'enjeux qui explique à
la fois la difficulté de venir avec des
propositions concrètes rapidement et en
même temps le sentiment que j'ai que
tous veulent le faire et ils veulent le
faire le plus sérieusement possible
lors de ce point de vue voilà où on en
est je pense que on aura un meilleur
tableau déjà d'ici quelques semaines
certainement donc entre le 1er et le 15
ou le 20 juin et une nouvelle vague qui
vont arriver dans le courant de l'été
dans le courant du mois d'août du début
du mois de septembre
alors où est ce qu'on en est sûre les
grands points de la négociation peut
être un petit peu de deux technologies
de la négociation comment est ce qu'on
fait vous savez qu être président de la
conférence des parties
en principe nous prenons cette résidence
formellement le premier le 30 novembre
jusque là on travaille dans les
coulisses on le fait avec la présidence
péruvienne qui elle est officiellement
présidente jusqu'en jusqu'au 30 novembre
et donc on le fait est là pour beaucoup
de raisons d'abord pour pouvoir
travailler plutôt ce qu'on a commencé à
faire dès le mois de février et ensuite
pour s'associer à un pays en
développement écoutée respectée par part
disons les autres pays en développement
et cela nous permet de ne pas au fond ne
pas être vu simplement comme grands pays
européens qui voudraient éventuellement
imposer ses vues donc on essaie de ceux
de cette façon de se prémunir contre le
syndrome qui a très largement accepté la
présidence danoise à copenhague
donc l'association étroite avec le pérou
fait partie à mon sens des chances de
succès qu'on accumule pour paris du
capital politique on essaie de frais
pour paris la deuxième le deuxième chose
qu'on fait aussi du point de vue de la
technologie des négociations outre le
fait de mobiliser notre réseau
c'est d'organiser des réunions
informelles de négociation où on essaye
de faire rapprocher les points de vue on
l'a fait à lima en mars à paris en mai
on va encore continuer en juillet et en
septembre et là à des à différents
niveaux au niveau des chefs de
négociation des négociateurs ou des
ambassadeurs ou au niveau des ministres
donc on a eu un moment important la
cciad dix jours maintenant je confonds
un peu les dates je dois voyager trop
mais à petersberg à berlin où la
chancelière merkel et président hollande
comme vous l'avez vu ont conclu les
travaux de ce dialogue de petersberg où
on a vu à la fois que les choses
commençaient à devenir sérieuses c'est à
dire il y as et c'est évident une
volonté d'aboutir à paris il y encore
une fois vraiment le souhait d'y arriver
est de montrer par ses contributions
nationales l'attachement à cet accord
collectif et dans de lui donner ce
caractère universel mais maintenant nous
rentrons dans la phase difficile où
chacun évidemment ferme un peu les
positions parce que on doit discuter des
choses difficiles lequel sont elles ces
choses difficiles elles sont d'abord ces
grands points politiques non résolus
au fond ils sont au nombre de 4 4 ou 5
le premier c'est cet objectif de 2
degrés est ce qu'on arrive à à lui
donner un peu de chair un peu de concret
2° qu'est ce que ça veut dire alors
essayez 1 en 2010 en 2009 d'y arriver
2° était un proxy comme on dit une
approximation pour ne pas avoir un
chiffre de réduction absolue des
émissions mondiales à l'échelle 2050 à
l'horizon 2050 ou bien pour ne pas
traduire ça en terme de concentration
des émissions à un chiffre de
concentration des émissions donc 2
degrés en se référant scénarios du giec
était une manière de contourner
l'obstacle
alors on va garder cet objectif la
labellisation formel c'est essayer de
contenir les températures entre 1.5 et
en dessous de deux degrés s'est pas
revendications notamment des petites
villes et des pays africains mais aller
plus loin vers cet objectif vous avez
sans doute entendu dire soit le
président de la république
soit laurent fabius soit d'autre il
faudra essayer de dire en est à zéro
émission net à la fin du siècle où
l'idée encore qu'on doit éventuellement
réduire les émissions la commission
européenne propose le chiffre de - 60 %
des émissions mondiales par rapport à
2010 donc on a plusieurs versions pour
essayer d'indiquer quelque chose de
concret qui pourrait servir de guide
donc pas d'accord là dessus pour
l'instant en grande partie parce que on
a un problème de très simple d'une
équation à qui pourrait être une
équation à une inconnue
2° au fond ça corresponde quand même à
une certaine concentration des
températures si on sait que les pays
développés sont prêts à réduire leurs
émissions long tout s'annonçait déjà
2009 de 80 à 95% d'ici 2050
la seule inconnue qui restent à
l'équation c'est la réduction des
émissions du côté des pays en
développement et c'est ça qui fait
problème donc difficulté de donner des
chiffres parce que donnait un chiffre de
résultats le 450 particules par million
ou un chiffre de réduction des émissions
mondiales par soustraction et parce
qu'on sait ce que des pays développés se
sont engagés à faire était déjà
ambitieux et bien ça donne le reste du
chemin à parcourir pour les autres
émetteurs et notamment évidemment au
premier lieu la chine et l'inde a assez
vite d'ariane donc premier point
difficile on a plusieurs réponses à cela
on essaie de trouver des formules
peut-être pic des émissions le plus tôt
possible
l'idée qu'on pousse aux idées qui
progresse beaucoup qui est une idée qui
vient de la france de pousser chaque
pays a volontairement décrire son
scénario 2 d'évolution économique
compatible avec 2 degrés d'ici 2050 non
pas sous une forme d'engagement solide
mais plutôt d'une vision pour aussi
faire rentrer dans les esprits et puis
regardez qu'est ce que ça suppose comme
transformation problèmes technologiques
etc mais donc c'est sur la table
le deuxième grand sujet c'est évidemment
les finances puisque à la fois on sait à
copenhague en 2009 puis en 2010 plus
formellement engagé du côté des pays
développés à trouver 100 milliards
financés du nord vers le sud de façon
publique et privée le développement
sobres des pays en développement d'ici
2015 qu'on a beaucoup de difficultés
aujourd'hui encore à fournir exactement
qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà et plusieurs
estimations qui sont qui ont été publiés
notamment par la banque mondiale disant
que la financement public est de l'ordre
de 37 millions de 37 milliards par an
aujourd'hui
donc il faudrait augmenter quand même 7
ses financements et deuxième question
comment est-ce qu'on reconnaît identifie
le financement privé qui s'investit
aussi dans les objectifs climatiques
dans les pays en développement
tout ça fait partie de la discussion ce
qui est certain c'est que ce qu'ils sont
il faut obtenir d'ici paris c'est une
compréhension commune de ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on compte une
trajectoire et semblable d'augmentation
des finances publiques et privées d'ici
2020 et sans doute spécificité de ce
qu'on doit consacrer notamment au sujet
de l'adaptation changement climatique un
grand sujet et en particulier des pays
les plus pauvres
on a deux troisième grand sujet de débat
qui est la question de qui est liée à la
proue ce que je disais sur les
contributions une si ces contributions
sont insuffisantes ce qu'elles sont
elles seront très probablement ce qui
est normal comment est ce qu'on fait
pour les réviser à la hausse
comment est-ce que avant 2030 ou avant
2025 on instaure un mécanisme de revues
d'augmentation de ces contributions pour
qu'on se mettre sur cette fameuse c'est
cette ou ces fameuses trajectoire
compatible avec 2 degrés et là on a tout
un débat très difficile pour instaurer
ces cycles soit de façon mécanique soit
de façon plus flexible et là on a des
difficultés notamment
la chine est résistante à l'idée d'un
accord qu'on veut un ver est
régulièrement
3 troisième sujet difficile la
vérification et la mesure des progrès
des uns et des autres alors tout le
monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut un mécanisme de vérification et de
rapportage la nature de cette de cette
obligation le degré d' ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures pour vérifier
que les chiffres sont bien les mots font
évidemment l'objet du départ et
quatrièmement la grande question est au
fond est ce que on a les mêmes règles
pour tout le monde
ou est-ce que les mêmes obligations pour
tout le monde ou calais la nature et le
degré de la différenciation entre pays
développés et pays en développement sur
ses obligations
alors je veux pas être trop longue dont
je vais m'arrêter bientôt on a donc
devant nous un peu moins de 6 mois les
négociations formelles à la fin la
semaine de sept semaines qui vont
démarrer qui sont alors j'ai beaucoup
dit il faut accélérer le tempo parce que
nous voulons du côté de la présidence
française
à voir dès octobre quand même les
grandes lignes de ce que peut être la
corde on ne pas attendre le moment de
paris pour cela il faut accélérer le
rythme donc les messages d'accélération
sont très intentionnelle ils ont été
repris à différents niveaux
d'abord par le président de la
république ensuite par le laurent fabius
et je le relais tant que je peux pour
dire il faut qu'on octobre on sache où
est ce qu'on va qu'on est les grands
éléments du paquet du paquet politique a
finalisé à paris il y aura un moment
important du g7 de juin parce que la
chancelière merkel veut faire de ce g7
se présidence allemande un important
moment pour le climat notamment du point
de vue financier il y aura d'autres
moments importants en parallèle de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
où françois hollande et ban ki moon le
secrétaire général vont réunir un
certain nombre de chefs d'état pour
donner l'impulsion finale et nous aurons
avant le g20 une grande réunion à lima
en octobre pour traiter du sujet
financier
tout cela avant la coop de décembre il
ya un agenda en parallèle que sur lequel
je voudrais pas revenir parce que sinon
ce serait trop long mais on suit donc
une série à la fois de conférences de
mobilisation pour mobiliser les
entreprises
vous l'avez vu la semaine dernière à
paris il y aura d'autres étapes avant
paris de cette mobilisation des
entreprises soit sur les engagements
individuels soient les engagements des
feuilles de route sectorielle soit sur
les engagements en matière d'innovation
technologique
même chose du côté des autorités locales
même chose du côté des acteurs
financiers
donc ce que vous avez vu à paris il va
se reproduire pour d'autres acteurs à
lyon en juillet ensuite en septembre à
new york en octobre à lima comme je le
disais et sans doute avec d'autres
points de rendez vous en octobre à
genève ou à paris sont aussi partie de
ceux de ses autres agendas négociations
qu'on poursuit pour que lier un peu à la
fois un momentum politiques et beaucoup
de beaucoup de soutien
beaucoup de courage donné au
gouvernement pour s'engager davantage
je vous propose qu'à ce stade je m'en
tienne la queue alors je n'ai pas
répondu
enfin façon je pourrais pas répondre à
toutes vos questions en détail mais je
le ferai peut-être plus t'as plus petit
peu par p type sur la situation
particulière notamment des pays
africains afin qu'ils sont à la fois
très engagé plus engagés qu'auparavant
plus coordonnée qu'auparavant d'ailleurs
qui préparent des contributions
il ya des stratégies différentes mais la
plupart des pays africains sont engagés
dans une préparation je pense au sénégal
à l'ethiopie au kenya bien sûr à
l'afrique du sud mais aussi la
république centrafricaine a bien
d'autres au mozambique en fin donc on va
les voir arriver au courant de l'été la
préoccupation pour eux c'est moins la
réduction des émissions que l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques mais aussi
de s'engager du point de vue notamment
des sources d'énergie vers les énergies
propres et non pas de faire le moins
possible le passage par le charbon ou le
pétrole de faire tant que faire se peut
des programmes d'efficacité énergétique
suffisamment tôt pour me réduire le
poids du coût de l'énergie dans l'eure
dans leur croissance économique pour
notamment pour ceux qui ont évidemment
qui n'ont pas de ressources minières ou
pétrolières propre donc une mobilisation
assez grande des pays africains à une
attente très grande des pays africains
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique et la réponse que les pays
développés notamment du point de vue
financier seront un grand sujet
agricoles forêts aussi qu'il faut pas
oublier pour ces pays qui est très
important est ce qu'on peut avoir une
agriculture adaptée aux changements
climatiques
on va y avoir moins de précipitation
dans beaucoup de zones trop de
précipitation dans d'autres et que cette
agriculture cuisse faire suffisamment
vivre les populations locales pour que
l'on n'ait pas besoin de continuer cette
déforestation qui est aussi un grand
problème dans beaucoup de zones donc là
un petit peu mon lancement de balle et
puis évidemment je suis toute ouïe sur
vos questions quant à donner la parole à
jean bignon qui est le président du
groupe de travail sur les négociations
climatiques qui paie ensuite je suis le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères ont aussi là le souhait
légitime d'intervenir et après il ya
d'autres
d'autres membres des deux commissions
qui ont pendant intention de s'exprimer
merci monsieur plaisir merci madame
l'ambassadrice pour vous
pour vos propos que j'ai trouvé
rassurant parce que j'avais été un peu
inquiet en lisant dans la presse
récemment que vous aviez l'air plus
pessimiste que vous ne l'avez été
aujourd'hui vous avez été très positive
et c'est vrai que c'est encourageant
quand on mène une négociation aussi
difficile il ya probablement des jours
avec et des jours sans et peut-être le
jour on vous avez interrogé
vous n'aviez pas le train que vous avez
la plupart du temps à ça peut être
tracté aussi alors moi j'ai trois
questions un peu de technique au fond
parce que vous avez dit vous avez déjà
rappelé beaucoup de choses vous nous
avez parlé du dialogue de petersberg qui
n'est pas une expression qu'on voit
souvent dans la négociation
internationale mais je sais que c'est
une négociation qui fait c'est une
enceinte qui a été menée créé par les
allemands en 2010 donc après l'échec de
deux de copenhague pour renouer le
dialogue j'ai vu qu'il y avait une 35
pays qui participaient mais qu'elle est
qu'est-ce qui différencie petersberg du
reste de l'année goa par le pouvoir d'
influence de la chancelière
c'est une première question deuxième
question j'ai vu que le le prince albert
de monaco c'était avait sollicité alors
ça va paraître très bizarre ce que je
vais dire mais quelqu un qu un absent
des négociations ils soient réintégrés
c'est l'océan vous avez présidé l'iddri
très longtemps avec beaucoup de
détermination et vous avez mis l'océan
sur le devant de la scène à bien avec
beaucoup de détermination ce qui nous
vaut probablement aujourd'hui d'avoir à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
de septembre le une renégociation d'un
bout de monter gober qui manquait au
grand large
le prince s'inquiètent de ne pas voir
l'océan dans la négociation c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une que c'est sûr
réduction des gaz à effet de serre et
les réductions de gaz à effet de serre
on les imagine comme une donnée
terrestre et dans il ya toute une partie
de l'opinion publique notamment qui se
retrouvent dans la plateforme océan et
climat mais qui était un peu triste de
ne pas voir la prise en compte de
l'océan comme un formidable puits de
carbone et comme un formidable émetteurs
de d'oxygène j'ai participé hier matin
encore et que madame madame guèye gaye
qui est une chercheuse bien connu du crs
que vous connaissez bien
qui regrette ça aussi donc peut être
pourriez nous donner un mot
d'explication encore une fois je ne juge
pas il ya un parti pris qui a été donnée
mais pourquoi ne pas se donner la chance
de mettre l'océan dans la dans la partie
et puis peut-être un point encore rapide
j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya des gens qui
étaient qui joue un rôle un jeu les
cités parce qu'on s'était les chinois en
particulier qui joue un peu derrière le
rideau
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une stratégie
qui consiste à dire on est un pays
émergent c'est très difficile pour nous
et c est en même temps derrière le
rideau qui est la traduction de
l'expression anglaise
ils jouent un rôle très puissant en
matière de réflexion industrielles
nouvelles technologies innovations sans
sens là sans la dévoiler iter qui jouent
aux pauvres devant et derrière ils se se
construise un avenir dont je me réjouis
d'ailleurs pour le peuple chinois et
pour le monde entier
mais qui est un peu ambiguë par rapport
au rôle qu'ils prétendent jouer sur le
devant de la scène
est ce qu'on parle de ça est ce que ça
fait partie du du d'un sujet dans l'est
dans les négociations voilà très
rapidement trois points d'ender
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères
merci monsieur le président madame là
l'ambassadrice vous remercie allah pour
les goûts je suis plutôt de nature
extrêmement optimiste et la revend ce je
le serai peut-être un peu moins
je suis effectivement rapporteur de la
commune
du rapport de la commission des affaires
étrangères sur le dérèglement climatique
et précisément sur l'impact géopolitique
nous avons eu un certain nombre
d'auditions depuis le depuis quelques
temps et un certain nombre de
scientifiques y en ait ils sont plutôt
si je puis dire à la alarmiste non pas
sur le seuil de 2 degrés dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure mais plutôt sur une
échelle de 4 degrés celsius voire même
certains sont déjà sur des logiques de 4
à 6 degrés donc je je note avec intérêt
que les négociations porte simplement
sur une limitation à ne pas dépasser les
2 degrés donc quid de ce delta qui est
pas du tout une une hypothèse mais une
réalité qui a été développé à plusieurs
reprises par en tout cas dans l'ensemble
des auditions qu'on a pu avoir ça c'est
ma première remarque et j'aurai trois
questions est ce que vous pensez
si on reprend l'accord conclu entre les
etats-unis et la chine ont septembre ou
octobre dernier qui à eux deux
représentent à peu près 42 % du total
des gazelles des parements des émissions
de co2 est ce que vous considérez que
cet accord est plutôt une opportunité
plutôt un bon signe ou au contraire
est-ce que c'est typiquement le genre
d'accord qui peut mettre à mal les
négociations pour la coop 21 ma seconde
question un très justement sur
l'organisation vous avez dit à juste
titre qui convenait de mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs de notre société
particulièrement les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous savons à peu près que
dit les dix plus grandes entreprises
mondiales sur les 10 plus grandes parts
dont huit d'entre elles ont une activité
directement liés aux activités fossiles
comment vous arrivez à les mobiliser
justement puisque précisément l'objectif
de la cap 21 à l'encontre de leur
business plan puisque fondamentalement
leur structure économique et simplement
centrée sur les énergies fossiles et
encore une fois sur ces digues plus
grandes entreprises force est de
rappeler qu'il n'ya pas de banque
ça c'est ma deuxième question sur ma
troisième question en ce qui concerne le
le fond vert et éventuellement les aides
dédiées à un certain pays certain nombre
de pays en développement
il ya une ambiguïté sur la terminologie
puisque du en fonction du groupe auquel
on appartient on peut
lui donner une qualification juridique
alors soit l'aide est considéré par les
bailleurs de fonds comme étant une aide
et donc les bailleurs de fonds ont un
droit de regard sur la manière dont les
fonds sont utilisés soit si on est du
côté entre guillemets des pays qui se
considère comme étant victime de la
surconsommation du nord pour la faire
schématique soit cette aide est
considérée comme étant une tête de cette
pollution des pays développés et dans ce
cas ils n'ont pas le droit
il n'y a pas de raison que permettent et
autorise un droit de regard est ce que
cette notion est définitivement est-ce
que c'est des sujets sur lesquels vous
êtes travailler afin justement d'éviter
des interprétations qui demain seront
sujets à discussion et un blocage ou en
tout cas qui ne permettront pas des
avancées significatives pour lutter
justement contre le lait les commandes
hier les gaz à effet de serre et enfin
j'avais dit 3 excusez moi j'avais une
quatrième question je finirai là dessus
un sujet qui me paraît extrêmement
important compte tenu donc et je
reviendrai sur mon introduction sur mon
propos plutôt sur un schéma à 4° non pas
à deux donc avec comme conséquence
directe des déplacements de populations
extrêmement important nous avons eu un
certain nombre d'auditions sur lequel
nous avons posé la question de savoir si
la france se soucie avait réfléchi ou en
tout cas portaient le sujet de la notion
juridique soit de déplacé on l'appellera
comme on veut mais simplement pour
proposer l'idée soit de déplacés
environnementaux soient de réfugiés
climatiques
il nous apparaît en tout cas clairement
à l'issue des différentes auditions que
nous avons pu avoir que la france n'a
pas tranché ce sujet et en ce qui me
concerne je m'excuse d'ailleurs pour mon
collègue cédric perrin qui avait une
contrainte
en ce qui nous concerne il nous semble
en tout cas qu'il est peut être
important pour la france qu'elle se
saisisse de ce sujet puisque les
déplacés climatiques ou la définition
qu'on voudra bien en données sont pas
une lubie mais quelque chose qui enfin
un phénomène qui arrivera est ce que la
france n'a pas intérêt à anticiper
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore un pays
influent dans 20 ou 30 ans ce sera
peut-être pas le cas
est-ce qu'on n'a pas encore intérêt à
influer justement aujourd'hui apporter
ce sujet parce qu'en tout cas ce qui est
ressorti de nos différentes auditions
c'est que c'est un sujet qu'on évite
pour dérision en tout cas de politique
intérieure qu'on peut comprendre mais ce
n'est pas le débat
je vous remercie j'aurais peut-être
ajouter dans le prolongement de ce qu'a
dit dsk évoqué leila aichi à quel niveau
2 de chiffrage allez dire vous placez le
succès de cette conférence
on vient d'avoir l'expérience en avril
la conférence de l'onu sur les risques
naturels qui s'est soldée je crois vers
le 18 mars par un casier chaque fois il
y avait une sympathique déclarations il
n'y avait aucun objectif chiffré il y
avait aucun financement et aucune
sanction
comment dans le rôle qui est le vôtre
tentez-vous d'imposer ou en tous les cas
de faire accepter un certain nombre de
chiffrage précis de telle sorte que là
aussi on évite le danger des conférences
internationales qui se termine par des
belles déclarations mais qui n'ayant pas
d'objectif n'ayant pas de sanction est
l'occasion pour les pays en
développement n'ayant pas d'aidé
financière prévus aboutissent finalement
pas grand chose très simple vraiment
très sympa je vais prendre un peu dans
l'ordre ce dialogue de petersberg c'est
typiquement le la manière d'essayer de
au fond d'eux d'éclaircir les points
politiques que les négociateurs n'arrive
pas à trancher dans le processus
multilatéral
habituellement c'est la même chose que
ce qu'on fait lorsqu'on va organiser d
informelle au niveau ministériel ou que
les états unis organisent en invitant au
sein du forum des économies majeures
aussi au niveau des chefs de délégations
ou des eaux des ministres on a besoin de
ce type d'enceintes pour un peu vaincre
l'inertie du système multilatéral qui
est compliqué en essayant de dans un
dans des enceintes où on ne négocie pas
mais on essaie de se comprendre on
essaie d'identifier des convergences ou
de bien éclaircir les divergences
d'avancé pour qu'ensuite on traduisent
puisque il faut toujours se souvenir que
des négociations multilatérales ce sont
des négociations de juristes et vous
parliez de l'océan et c'est ça et donc
dé négocier un texte juridique vous
connaissez les juristes et d'un grande
rigueur c'est très compliqué donc on
veut très précis donc il faut au moins
des monts ça y est les concerts
pour savoir si on peut trouver la
formule est donc d'où l'intérêt de ces
de ces enceintes plus politique qui
essaie de se dire bon fond comment va
trouver les 10 les différents compromis
donc c'est l'utilité
je pense que ç'a bien fonctionné cette
année aussi
c'est un bon tout une bonne
représentation de dix ans de la
diversité du pays un cétacé en général
suffisamment divers pour qu'on y
retrouve les différents groupes de
négociations les différentes catégories
de pays l'a peut-être la difficulté
c'est que les on a besoin d'atterrir sur
des sujets concrets on a balayé un peu
large mais ça a été au fond la première
discussions ministérielles que nous
avions depuis le début de l'année donc
de ce point de vue elle a été très
importante et la chancelière avait
laissé à la france beaucoup de place
pour donner notre vision des choses
donc ça nous a été très utile même
s'agissant des océans et le malheur qui
veut qu'ils soient des puits de carbone
qui évidemment des grades énormément
lassitude l'écosystème océanique dans
son entier à cause de ces concentrations
élevées dans l'atmosphère je pense que à
la fois ya beaucoup de pays qui ont
envie que on traite des sujets des
océans
il faut trouver la formule et c'est pas
simple les forêts au fond qui a été un
peu le premier écosystème qui a été
touchée la question de la
désertification est un peu la même
enfin dans des problèmes très différents
mais au fond les forêts on l'attaqué des
deux côtés c'était à la fois un puits de
carbone mais qu'on pouvait
éventuellement protégé puisque si on
évite la déforestation
on évite de perdre toutes ses codes
tonnes de carbone stockée accumulé puis
ont permis de régénérer aussi cette
forêt et
la question de l'océan c'est comment
est-ce qu'on freine cette acidification
comment est ce que justement c'est pas
l'océan qui est la variable d ajustement
majeur qui va rapidement vers une
détérioration de la faune et de la flore
des coraux enfin je ne vous fais pas le
tableau puisque vous le connaissez très
bien donc c'est à la fois très important
de parler des océans et en même temps
par quel biais on attaque sans ça il
reste que c'est au fond la conséquence
de nos actions qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
protéger les océans à ce qu'il ya des
des choses qu'on peut faire déjà il ya
des choses assez évidente mais qui sont
l'exploitation des trucs du sous sol
on peut essayer de faire moins grave
mais quand même l'enjeu essentiel pour
les océans c2c de réduire les émissions
mondiales
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à faire donc
ou bien tu accroître les capacités
d'absorption par d'autres fuites carbone
qui sont les sols ces deux problèmes en
grand sujet qui est en train d'émerger
hautement par l'agriculture la
fertilisation des sols qui permettrait
de justement de soulager un peu
l'absorption des des océans et aussi par
la meilleure gestion des forêts dont il
ya dix ans nous font tourner autour du
sujet océan parce que le sujet océans
pour l'instant c'est un sujet d' impact
du changement climatique
davantage qu'un sujet de solutions et
donc c'est à la fois un point important
et en même temps si on le mettait
n'importe où ce samedi rsa saint-pierre
à rien on parlerait de l'océan pour
parler de l'océan et j'en discute
beaucoup avec mes collègues du monde des
océans qui voudraient bien que le sur
ocean apparaissent partout et en même
temps on n'a pas encore trouvé comment
est ce que on traite cela autrement que
en essayant de se donner peut-être s'est
pas encore mûr mais ça pourrait mettre
peut-être en passant par les processus
scientifique de se donner des objectifs
en matière de au fonds de 7,2 cette
absorption ça pour être en verre d'eau
donc on y réfléchit et quelques papiers
je crois qu'on en avait publié à l'iddri
à l'époque de se donner un peu une
vision
mais je dois dire que d'ici paris avant
une mention y aura une mention sur des
océans à plusieurs endroits une solution
est à dire un objectif par exemple
chiffré pour les océans je pense que
l'on n'en est pas encore là alors sur
sur cette question chinoise s'est pas
vraiment derrière le rideau
la chine est le premier investisseur en
matière d'énergies renouvelables est
aussi premier investisseur en charbon
dans les centrales à charbon
cela dit elle est en train de prendre un
virage considérable puisque alors c'est
pas clair et on va voir si c'est dans la
contribution chinoise hong pas elle se
donne un objectif en matière de
limitation puisse de décroissance de la
consommation de charbon en chine
donc c'est un peu comme le débat enfin
très différemment c'est un peu comme le
débat nucléaire renouvelable ici en
france on a le même type de débat en
chine il ya des gens qui disent quand
même on a cette ressource pourquoi
lagache et on sait faire c'est ça qu'a
fait le gros de notre industrialisation
pourquoi commencer à faire quelque chose
d'autre et d'autres qui disent mais au
contraire bon c'est la pollution locale
enfin on peut trouver vous prenez le
débat aux états unis enfin on a quand
même beaucoup de parallèles
donc je dirais pas que c'est que la
chine veille à la fois faire elle-même
et parier sur l' économie sobre en
carbone c'est absolument vrai et c'est
ça le changement fondamental qu'on a
observée depuis 2010 c'est ce changement
de la vision de la chine sur son
économie en 2009 parlé d' économie sobre
en carbone en chine
c'était une menace aujourd'hui même les
négociateurs chinois disent ce qu'il
nous faut dans l'accord de paris c'est
quelque chose qui crédibilise qui fasse
qu on aille tous vers une économie sobre
en carbone
donc pour eux c'est une priorité il veut
pas y aller tout seul pour des raisons
comme nous on voudrait pas aller tout
seul dans cette direction là aussi pour
des raisons de compétitivité et
d'intégration d'économie mondiale donc
c'est pas derrière le rideau ce qui est
ce qu'ils veulent pas ce qu'ils essaient
de protéger le plus possible c'est leur
propre rythme leurs propres décisions et
donc ils veulent le moins d'obligations
internationales possible mais la
direction dans lequel ils vont aller
pas contestable d'ailleurs pas brouiller
on le voit à travers et les décisions
qui ont été prises certainement la
préparation du troisième plan on va
avoir quelque chose d'intéressant il y
aura la contribution chinoise
probablement mois de juin et et des
éléments très concrets de mise en oeuvre
déjà dans les décisions prises pour le
13ème plan qui courent donc de 2016 à
2005 ans plus tard donc à de 2021
on aura les mesures assez précise fin
août
donc je pense le pain du sérieux de
encore une fois dans un débat féroce
parce qu'en chine
tous portent sur quel est le taux de
croissance sur lequel on parie pour les
15 prochaines années ce qui est un sujet
éminemment politique
on sait qu'un sujet d'économie c'est un
sujet est ce qu'on dit qu'on va être à
10% par an et que tout repose donc sur
cette course effrénée aux 10% par an où
est-ce qu'on est à cinq ou est ce qu'on
à 6 61 7 et c'est ça qui fait les
scénarios chinois en réalité presque
tous les instituts de recherche chinois
y compris pense que les émissions
mondiales peuvent chinoises peuvent se
réduire à partir de 2025
mais ils ne veulent pas s'engager à ça
parce que s'engager à ça ça voudrait
dire déjà faire un pari taux de
croissance relativement faible pour
l'instant donc le découplage tant qu'on
n'est pas complètement sur le découplage
peut s'affirmer de plus en plus entre
énergie consommation d'énergie est
particulièrement d'énergies fossiles et
pibe la variable d'ajustement c'est le
taux de croissance du pib est donc c'est
il est compréhensible que ça soit un peu
derrière le rideau parce que c'est juste
que c'est un sujet politique
super difficile encore une fois je me
réfère aux débats que qu'elle avait
beaucoup participé sur la transition
énergétique dire on divise par deux la
consommation d'énergie française en 2050
ça avait l'air de dire qu'on sacrifiait
l'économie française c'est exactement le
genre de débat encore une fois alors sur
cette question du du cat de grève que
vous avez posé manama enfin que vous
imposez vous constatez que les le les
conclusions de nos collègues de l'ipc
sans fin du giec et des climatologues
français vous avez sûrement auditionné
se fondent quand même sur des
contributions qu'ils sont enfin c'est le
business à jules de maintenant c'est ça
4° 4 au dessus de 4 encore une fois il
faut voir ce que nous donne la récolte
de ces premières contributions on sera à
ce moment là encore une fois c'est une
trajectoire et c'est des probabilités 1
c'est pas des déterminations mécanique
plutôt quelque chose entre 3 et 4 3 3
degrés ou trois degrés et demi
je pense que enfin tout l'objectif de
l'accord c'est de se donner un mécanisme
pour faire que cette trajectoire qui
passent plutôt qu'ils nous donnent plus
de 50% de chances de probabilités d'être
au-dessus de 3 degrés en stabilisé
puisque c'est pas une date précise que
que ceci se passe assez effectivement de
prévoir ces mécanismes ou en va
accentuer l'effort et pourquoi on
accentuerait l'effort dans le futur
c'est pour des raisons assez simple on
voit qu'on y arrive de les technologies
coûte de moins en moins chères et tout
le monde le fait et donc il ya un
intérêt à le faire
donc oui il faut à la fois voir si les
contributions qui sont proposés font
déjà faire un changement ça c'est le
premier consacré un portrait est ce que
ce changement est quand même
significatif ou est ce qu'au fond c'est
pas très différent de ce que craignent
noko les climatologues en disant c'est
le 'business as usual' et celui là
aujourd'hui quand on regarde ce qui se
passe ça nous met à 4 degrés dans
première chose et deuxième chose comment
on relève
l'ambition de cet accord donc c'est ça
le succès de paris
il n'est pas gagné ce succès se
succèdent paris c'est au minimum d'avoir
un mécanisme qui nous permet de revenir
de faire le constat de où on en est de
conserver l'objectif global est de se
donner les états par lequel on va
arriver et ses étapes c'est pas juste
seulement de se revoir tous les cinq ans
pour dire on fait mieux c'est de mettre
en place ce qu'il faut en matière
d'investissement de recherche et
développement sur les technologies en
matière de financement international
pour qu'on y arrive donc sa dépose de
beaucoup des moyens ce qu'on appelle des
moyens de mise en oeuvre de la de la
convention donc le avoir une chance 50%
de chance au moment où 60% de chances de
guy arriver à ces deux degrés ne pas les
dépasser plus tôt c'est quand même aussi
tous ses moyens de mise en oeuvre qui va
falloir éclaircir dans l'accord de paris
voilà pour l'audition de laurence
tubiana laurence tubiana et notre
représentante spéciale pour la coop 21
notre ambassadrice en charge des
négociations sur le changement
climatique elle interviendra lors de
cette fameuse conférence des nations
unies qui va se tenir à la fin de
l'année à paris dans trois mois donc une
conférence avec un enjeu essentiel
elle doit faire en sorte que les 195
pays participant arrive à conclure un
accord contraignant pour réduire leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre cela
pour limiter à deux degrés la hausse des
températures sur notre planète
2° c'est la limite au-delà de laquelle
les scientifiques prévoient des dégâts
irréversibles
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur